you burn one you burn us all the small
town women may not get along Ashley
McBride says this is a thing welcome
Ashley McBride we are also excited
you're here so this album
came about you said you were just
hanging out with friends and I'm
wondering about your friends because one
of the song titles best song title ever
Brenda put your bra on Brenda it's about
somebody who's a cheater cheater pumpkin
eater with the babysitter a friend says
we're gonna go get him oh yeah
absolutely we all got that friend that
like sleeps through whatever the
happenings are so put on your problems
let's go to the port the drama unfold so
this album you you didn't you were doing
it for fun you didn't really think it
would get made what was your thinking
yeah we weren't writing these songs an
album so it's myself Nicolette Hayford
Aaron rates here Connie Harrington Benji
Davis and Brandy Clark so you guys are
just playing around right and so we're
writing songs and I was like you know we
should do we've got all these characters
we've kind of developed over the years
we should give all those characters
neighbors and a place to live yeah so we
put ourselves in a house for four or
five days somewhere was there alcohol
involved well I would say that the
chances are High
um and then we spent the time just
writing what we wanted to write and
sometimes that was a jingle for a diner
and sometimes it was bonfire at Tina's
and we didn't intend to make it a record
but then things kept happening so that
it had to be arrested so people always
say do things with intention how did
doing things without intention yes
Our intention was to have fun so at
least we had that we just do what feels
good but what we did was we just took
the word should out of the equation as
far as like what normal things should
happen yeah and then I was like you know
we should do is we should write these
songs and then we did we should get them
and then what we should do is try to do
some demos and I was like unless we make
it a record yeah that'll never happen
right if John Osborne will produce it
we'll make it a record and then he said
yes like Okay We're Off to the Races
yeah and you didn't think that this
would get a green light from your label
at first it there's a really good chance
that it won't right right not everything
gets a green light right so we let
everybody hear it and they're like oh
yeah oh yeah we love it right my
favorite is the girl in the picture if
she thank you thank you I'd love to I
love that song that's my personal
recommendation but it's really something
actually that you're even sitting with
us today you know you had a very serious
horse accident you had to fall from the
horse and I thought how did I miss that
did you not really talk about it at the
time because this was very serious you
could have really been incapacitated or
even worse it was pretty bad yeah and
you didn't talk about it why we did kind
of put out there that there had been an
accident that that had been horse
specific wreck and that some shows were
going to have to be canceled but we
didn't even know the extent of my
injuries until all the Imaging came back
and a little while later but
um life-saving measures were taken yeah
and you actually know how to ride a
horse oh yeah and you fell
was not her fault and as they say did
you get back on the horse that is a
great figure of speech and um I did I
got to go visit the horse's name is
Jenny and I got to go visit her this
last week to make sure I I thought I
thought it was to tell her I was okay
she doesn't care okay but it was to make
sure that I knew I was okay and to look
at Bart and Wendy and Caroline the
people that were there and helped save
my life I felt terrible to look at them
and and really just know that they put
breath into my lungs for me so that I
would live I had a nurse they literally
did put breath literally and to be able
to look at them and say thank you for
saving my life and then they came to the
show that night of course in Missoula
and to be able to tell at least one
crowd I get to stand here because of the
measures they took but you also said
that sometimes it's hard for you to ask
for help and then you put yourself out
there and said I'm vulnerable and I need
help and that was life-changing for you
it was and I know that I probably should
have waited a little longer to get on
stage I feel like six days after
something that
yeah the doctor wanted 30 and she came
back in like a week or so yeah it was
about six days I'm doing okay yeah okay
we are so glad you're here we're not the
only ones who are glad to see you here
we have a special surprise for you oh
maybe somebody that you know him or her
where's our special surprise where hey
it's Garth Brooks you know Garth Brooks
Ashley can you see him working here
say hi to Ashley it's Gail Tony and Nate
here hey Garth
hey everybody good morning good morning
Miss Ashley
I know you look excited thank you
thank you right what's happening
you got any news for Ashley I'm here for
a proposal
oh I would love it Miss Ashley yes I am
but this is part of a family that keeps
growing I you know where we're at we're
at the Grand Ole Opry I'm standing in
the circle of wood right now where you
stand Miss Ashley McBride on behalf of
the Opry and myself as adopt remember
but try not to cry
we would love for you to consider
becoming the newest member of the Grand
Ole Opry
um
it would be um
the great joy and the great honor of my
life thank you oh goodness pretty cool
it's the it's the longest living family
in music history you belong in it we
need you you will make us stronger for
decades to come I love you
congratulations couldn't happen to a
sweeter person and coming from you Garth
Brooks means so much Ashley what what
are you thinking right now why is this
so emotional this is a lifelong um
this is I mean there's Grammys and
there's being a member of the Grand Ole
Opry are the two
greatest things that could ever happen
to you that's an Entertainer and um I've
I've always said I will earn it and
this is a pretty surreal
moment Garth she has earned it hasn't
she she's earned it big time well then
100 there isn't anybody in this family
who hasn't because it's it's the love
they show for The Operators the respect
they show for country music and try to
remember it is the longest living family
in music history so Grammys CMAs they're
all going to fade this won't this will
be until the day they put you in the
ground you will be part of the coolest
show on the planet
wow congratulations good morning thank
you I can't wait to see you and hug you
goodness I love you very much you keep
tearing them up okay
oh well thank you Garth thank you so
much thank you very much
wanted to be here to do that thank you
wow thank you thank you Tony appreciate
it of course by Garth it has been so
hard to keep this secret your team knew
your team knew what a moment and we knew
but all those people in there all those
people in there we should get a shot of
the Green Room of other people yeah
right especially when Garth when Garth
popped up everybody went yay who is the
lady in the blue who is that there they
are right there oh
who is that lady in the blue
when I came back to gratitude so you
know hi Mom
wow did you hear the news yes
where did mom come from she wasn't in
the green Arkansas you can't even get
there from here
congratulations you have a wonderful
daughter as you know wonderful daughter
Ashley thank you so much we are so happy
so much
we're going to take a break actually
McBride our new album is called
lindeville it's on sale now wherever you
buy your albums we'll be right back